the amount of false information being
posted online about medicine and science
has surged
during the pandemic youtube temporarily
suspended republican senator ron johnson
on friday
for violating its medical misinformation
policy
the wisconsin lawmaker had posted a
video where he advocated for unproven
covid treatments
dr taran arula shows us what social
media companies like youtube
are doing to stop the spread of
misinformation it is a big
problem uh doctor good morning to you
good morning tony
as it turns out we have an emotional
relationship to information
and i learned misleading information
often spread so quickly
out of fear companies are now finding
innovative ways to try to nip the issue
in the bud
and on the ground efforts are being made
to educate communities
and arm them with accurate fact-based
information
we're trying to give some information on
the vaccine to our people in the
community
for over three decades nurse kathy avery
has made it her mission to offer medical
education
through door-knocking under-served
communities in north carolina
a lot of these people are low-income no
income
and for me it breaks my heart because
people aren't
trying to give health care in these
environments and so the only person they
may have
is me well help us pass the word okay
okay
it's a grassroots effort to combat
misinformation
and conspiracy theories you need the
vaccine for real
if you can't see how people really live
then you can't help them when you're out
there door-to-door and you're talking
one-on-one with people you can hear
all the craziness that they've read on
facebook and then you can give them real
information
so it's understandable so it's not
misunderstood
the challenge is that most of us don't
have the training or the background to
discern fact versus fiction
jennifer granston leads the team at
signal a leading media intelligence
company that is working to track
and report medical misinformation you'll
see here
bill gates created the virus that a
million mentions 5g causes covid at
about a half a million
we still see things around
hydroxychloroquine these things
tend to spin and spin and spin since the
start of the pandemic the company has
pulled in
over three billion stories related to
misleading and false narratives around
covid
and the vaccine oftentimes you can see
within the hashtags
of what's being shared a more deliberate
effort to spread
misinformation and you can sometimes
trace that back to
a particular group or a set of actors
that are doing that a government census
recently found that 36 percent
don't trust the vaccine almost 29 don't
trust the government
do those numbers correlate with what
you're seeing absolutely
but our job is to really identify those
things that we see emerging online and
put it in the hands of the people that
are going to be able to make decisions
with it
in the hands of social media platforms
like twitter and youtube
misinformation has dire public health
consequences
dr garth graham heads a new youtube
partnership with
well-trusted health organizations like
the american public health association
and mayo clinic to counter myths with
fact-based medical videos so we give
them the science
but in the culturally specific and
culturally appropriate way
video allows you to deliver digestible
information
in the right format and reach people in
the right way your body's not making
the whole virus you can't get the
infection from the vaccine
what vulnerability did covet expose in
terms of
our ability to get information to the
consumer what covid
showed was that we needed to do a better
job
of at least first empowering individuals
with information immediately
as we develop the science and
disseminate the science we have to be
able to
give people that information in a timely
manner we need to reach people where
they are where their minds are at where
their hearts are at
that's why on the ground community
efforts by people like kathy
is crucial how do you convince them that
your information
is correct and not what they heard last
week
uh at their gathering with their friends
or
on facebook you have to keep listening
you have to let them say what they think
and they feel
because then they feel respected they
feel heard and that's the only way
you're going to change people
the minds if it's going to happen at all
is to show that you're willing to listen
and not just listen but understand where
they're coming from
i also spoke with claire wardle who is
advising the biden administration on
combating medical misinformation
she says it's critical to build trust
one-on-one in communities
to have conversations based on empathy
and to realize that we can all be
potential publishers and
vectors of misinformation if we're not
careful there's a responsibility we have
every time we comment retweet or share
on social media
it is important to be mindful that our
actions have ripple effects that spread
way beyond us
and our immediate contacts such an
interesting point you make tara that
misinformation can
essentially be emotional that it that
because people develop fear it tran
it it travels much faster that's right
it used to be so obvious what the
difference was between good information
and bad there was an authoritative
encyclopedia of medicine and then there
was the flyer underneath your windshield
wiper and
now they're both just on twitter and you
have to make a different distinction
that's right but the importance of that
one-on-one connection like what nurse
kathy was doing is huge especially
you know stories are done on healthcare
on vaccine hesitancy
doctors keep saying it's when you're
one-on-one with the patient in the room
or you know on the virtual meeting where
you can convince people i'm sure you've
had that's
exactly what i find in my practice it's
that one-on-one those couple minutes
where you just spend to explain it and
to educate
and then suddenly the patient says okay
i think i'm going to get it so
all right tara thank you